According to a most successful information broker, people who control information are the most powerful and wealthy.
The delivery of crucial information at the right time is one of the most lucrative businesses.
Interestingly, you can literally get information for free and all you need is a little ingenuity.
The absolute largest source is the U.S. Government.
The information they hold on virtually any subject is staggering. And it's free.
You merely need to find customers who are willing to pay for specialized information.
Introduce yourself as an information broker who can find any information,...
...but do zero in on particular types of information.
Alternatively, collect specialized information of interest to a particular sector,...
...write comprehensive special reports and sell them in an e-book.
You could make money on subscriptions if you create a newsletter that features regular updates.